tu mens la musique s'arrête à une dame
qui veut passer derrière toi à maxime et
des paillis ou bien dans livres y allant
lui lécher les attentions
on est attention cela pose à tous les
abonnés à la pause la moins sexy
jean monnet pour moi qui ai franchement
c'est maxime guaino oui mais les sallois
sous sols non mais alors ils sont les
seuls maxime dany vous allez mathieu
ah ah ah ah
je voyais la pause la plus pourrie
c'est jean michel baylet la nuit ok
jean-michel mais aminé retournez vous
asseoir attention si nos rêves
attention mes démons par équipes mais
c'est vous par écrit monsieur hop les
bateaux de la mi-été vous donne afin
qu'ils plat
l'appareil un des deux minutes j'étais
derrière c'est pas du tout sur les
chaînes 3 2 à
julien sait pas trop si julien benneteau
n'est pas parce que j'ai attrapé process
de moi sexy pour moi alors vous ça vous
fait quoi mais je crois que vous avez
perdu vos clés ceux qui se battent pour
la peau à peau de la pause cameron 30
attention n'ont jamais dansé cinéma mais
pour moi elle est très sexy mamie c'est
julien
m
on adore alors c'est pas dit ouah c'est
moi allons sélectionner le manche est
notament ses potes mais les parties
complètement ottawa matthieu delormeau
vous fait beaucoup de peine des bouts de
faciliter leur chien il fait toujours la
même chose mais ça lui irait bien sûr
elle n'a jamais eu envie de péter stein
j'aimerais un truc je l'adoré je vends
d'éliminer deux cette fois ci bas vous
vous avez bougez-vous gens mais tu n y
croient je vais même parti directement
au final 1 1
au final chaque finale va opposer
isabelle mathieu mathieu delormeau
oui oui je crois grosse la nuit c'est
mon métier c'est mon métier ce n'est pas
réellement et les bosses
ridha ben on le rappelle que les plages
la quotidienne de demain avec attention
la chanson que j'ai choisi une chanson
que j'adore et une chanson de britney
spears et les données pas des comme vous
attention c'est parti
3 2 1
et
ouais
aulas membres
devenir franchement j'aime beaucoup les
deux oui mais mais s'il vous plaît les
jo dit je vais donner deux notes et note
artistique en note artistique isabelle
c'est une note sur 10 je vous mets 6
matthieu delormeau en note artistique
je vous mets ça qu on note technique
isabelle je vous mais vous rigolez
non non règle 1 mathieu comme je vous
met vite cette saison mathieu de
lamballe
non